ich glaube hier herrscht immer noch
sprachlosigkeit aber das kann ich auch
direkt mein gesprächsgast fragen
bundesgeschäftsführer jörg schindler wir
haben gestern abend kurz nach 18 uhr
gesprochen da waren sie noch frohen
mutes und haben gesagt na ja vielleicht
kommen wir doch ein bisschen über die
fünf prozent jetzt sieht es nach 4,9
prozent aus wie war denn ihre nacht na
gut also es war schon eine schwere nacht
die wir jetzt hatten alle als partei
denn wir haben deutlich verloren das
muss man auch klar so sagen wir sind
natürlich enttäuscht sehr enttäuscht
über das ergebnis
gleichwohl will ich aber zumindest sagen
wir sind weiterhin im bundestag
vertreten wir sind weiterhin als linke
die soziale die ökologische auch die
antirassistische kraft und es bleibt so
wie es ist dass wir natürlich die punkte
die uns im wahlkampf wichtig waren das
wird ihr auch jetzt einbringen in den
nächsten tag wir werden eine zukünftige
bundesregierung egal wie sie aussieht
natürlich daran messen welche wie sie
diese zukunft ausgabe aufgaben die wir
haben wie sie die bewältigen will und
ich will daran erinnern es geht um rente
es geht um mindestlohn erhöhungen die
spd hat das jahr gefordert es geht um
einen mieten stoppt das hat die spd
gefordert wir wollen die mieten deckeln
es geht darum wie wir auch den sozial
ökologischen umbau die investitionen
hinbringen ich erinnere daran auch spd
und grüne haben die vermögenssteuer
gefordert
da werden wir im bundestag wo wir ja
jetzt durchaus auch weiterhin vertreten
sind druck machen dass das geschieht das
ist unsere aufgabe die nehmen wir jetzt
an und natürlich haben wir auch in der
partei ein paar dinge zu klären das will
ich ihnen auch so deutlich sagen da
werden wir jetzt im als parteivorstand
heute aber jetzt auch am kommenden
wochenende in der klausur natürlich
darüber beraten gehen diesmal punkt für
punkt durch sie haben gerade
angesprochen die spd und die grünen
hatten das auch bei denen hat sich das
aber in den prozenten niedergelegt warum
hat das bei der linken nicht
funktioniert sie haben auch mieten
deckel sie hatten die vermögenssteuer
sie haben über das rentenniveau 53% sie
hatten mindestlohn auch als thema das
hat bei den anderen beiden wunderbar
funktioniert warum hat die linke aber
nicht die wählerinnen und wähler
erreicht damit nun ja also das sind
dinge da wo ich jetzt auch nicht von
vornherein sagen kann ich kann für alles
eine erklärung bieten wir prüfen das wir
analysieren das natürlich jetzt auch
anhand unserer zahlen das ist klar ich
will nur sagen dass wir in den punkten
natürlich klar waren offenbar anders
aber die wählerinnen und wähler noch
nicht so überzeugend gefunden dass sie
sich vorstellen konnten mit uns das
durchzusetzen so und da würden wir
gucken wie wir unseren politischen
veränderungs anspruch stärken können das
müssen wir als partei da haben wir in
den letzten jahren durchaus auch wohl
ein paar defizite das muss man auch so
sehen dass wir also zeigen wir können
mit einem klar mit einer klaren
positionen die politisch notwendigen
veränderungen auch durchsetzen und da
dürfen wir natürlich uns keine
uneindeutigkeit 'nen leisten die gab es
in der partei das will ich sagen
durchaus in der einen oder anderen
stelle auch da müssen wir drüber die
gibt es jetzt auch weiterhin also wenn
man so die sozialen netzwerke und sich
mal betrachtet hat dann sagt frau
kipping dass herr ramelow äußert sich
dazu frau wagenknecht sagt na ja wir
hätten in der korona krise einfach auch
deutlicher sein müssen das heißt diese
vielen stimmen die es in der linken
politik gibt die gab es auch jetzt
gestern abend direkt wieder danach bat
sie das oder sagen sie ja das ist doch
genau das an denen wir arbeiten müssen
eigentlich ich stimme ihnen zu es ist so
dass wir als partei natürlich bei den
drängenden gesellschaftlichen fragen und
das ist natürlich einerseits die soziale
frage das ist zum zweiten die
ökologische frage das ist aber auch die
frage zum beispiel noch offenen
einwanderungsgesellschaft die wir ja
gestalten müssen als linke das ist aber
auch die frage wie wir etwa den
pflegenotstand bekämpfen müssen dass wir
dort klare und eindeutige lösungen
vorstellen müssen vorschläge machen
müssen das gelingt uns zum teil aber
offenbar ist bei den wählerinnen und
wählern zum teil auch in bei einigen
punkten eine unklarheit was wir da
vertreten würden und das ist aber unsere
aufgabe dort klarheit herzustellen ich
meine jetzt auch das personelle
innerhalb der linken wie sehr glauben
sie hat diese agenda wagenknecht
lafontaine diese ganzen
auseinandersetzungen der vergangenen
monate vielleicht auch dass wählerinnen
und wähler verhalten beeinflusst es geht
meines erachtens eher weniger um
personen sondern darum wie wir als
partei eine klare politische position
formulieren und offenbar haben die
wählerinnen und wähler das müssen wir ja
auch so sehen uns nicht eindeutig
positioniert gesehen so und das müssen
wir jetzt auch klarstellen wir müssen
sagen ja wir stehen für die drängenden
menschheitsfragen mit einer klaren
politischen position wir brauchen einen
neuen sozialstaat das kann auch nicht
der alte sein sondern es muss ein neuer
sozialstaat sein wir brauchen ökologisch
sozial ökologischen umbau das muss klar
jetzt angegangen werden und natürlich
geht es auch zum beispiel bei der korona
krise darum dass wir dort für eine
solidarische lösung kämpfen jetzt sitzen
sie im bundestag darin sie haben es eben
gesagt mit hilfe von drei direktmandaten
gesine lötzsch der herr peymann und
gregor gysi aber man darf auch nicht
unterschlagen petra pau hat es nicht
geschafft dietmar steiner janine wissler
haben ihre direktmandate nicht
verteidigen können wie sehr schmerzt sie
das und wie sehr können sie aus der
opposition heraus dann die ganzen
inhalte die sie jetzt gerade skizziert
haben überhaupt noch umsetzen also vor
der also nach der wahl ist vor der wahl
und es geht ja auch darum dass wir
natürlich auf den
niederlagen die wir in den direkt
wahlkreisen etwa bei petra pau
eingefahren haben dass wir daraus die
schlüsse ziehen die konsequenzen ziehen
dass wir schauen wie können wir uns dort
wieder stärker verankern wie können wir
dort auch ansprechpersonen
ansprechpartnerin als partei für die
bürgerinnen und bürger sein wie können
wir ihre punkte so aufnehmen wie es etwa
dürren pellmann wie es aber auch gregor
gysi und gesine lötzsch geschafft hat
ich will aber trotzdem noch mal sagen
wir sind da als fraktion wieder drin und
alle unsere bundestagsabgeordneten
werden mit vollem herzblut dafür kämpfen
dass die soziale die ökologisch und auch
die antirassistische frage in der
gesellschaft hart von uns vertreten wird
das heißt ja jetzt auch nicht mit
personellen konsequenzen gleich um 10
uhr 30 gibt's ja noch eine
pressekonferenz aber da würde jetzt
keiner der drei also frau wissler
freihändig welzow oder herberg sagen mir
getreten zurück oder wir machen
irgendetwas und zu sagen wir machen
schon mal einen ersten schritt
also darum geht es doch jetzt gar nicht
es geht doch erstmal darum dass wir
politisch klären wie wir uns neu
aufstellen da haben wir als partei eine
ganze sache eine ganze frage zu klären
aber es ist auf keinen fall eine sache
die mir jetzt mit irgendwelchen personen
an der ein oder andere stelle zu
verknüpfen wäre sondern es geht hier um
eine politisch inhaltliche
neuaufstellung das erwarten die
wählerinnen und wähler von uns und ein
was will ich schon sagen also wer janine
wissler im wahlkampf gesehen hat der
weiß wie die neue linke aussehen könnte
und meines erachtens auch müsste
sagt der bundesgeschäftsführer hier
chandler vielen dank dass sie heute
morgen zu uns gekommen sind